the Pentagon is rolling out military
hardware for a fourth of July unlike any
other tanks on the National Mall and
military flyovers will be part of the
capital celebration by order of
President Trump he'll be the first
president to take an active role in any
July 4 ceremony in recent memory major
Garrett is near the Lincoln Memorial
where the president will speak tomorrow
night major you've got a long memory
what else is different about this event
so much is different about it but let's
talk about things that have captured a
lot of the national attention tanks and
armored infantry vehicles well let me
show you what's going on right now here
are the steps Lincoln Memorial and have
my photographer go over and show you
this forklift that's bringing these
protective slats to the platform here at
the Lincoln Memorial why we are led to
believe that is to make sure that when
those infantry vehicles and tanks are
rolled up here no damage is done to the
steps here at the Lincoln Memorial the
platform here so when we talk to the
National Park Service yesterday it told
us it was still waiting for the run of
show from the White House pretty strong
evidence that this is a show and it's
being staged managed by President Trump
[Music]
it is called a salute to America but
President Trump has made it clear the
military will be front and center we
have some incredible equipment military
equipment on display brand-new and we're
very proud of it tanks and infantry
vehicles will be on static display near
the Lincoln Memorial trucked in to
prevent their treads from damaging the
streets fighter jets Air Force one
marine one a b-2 bomber and the Blue
Angels will fly over these flyovers cost
tens of thousands of dollars per hour
though military officials say they are
essentially training flights and
therefore not an extra cost to taxpayers
but the National Park Service is
reportedly diverting nearly 2.5 million
dollars originally intended for parks
across the country for this celebration
certainly going to be more expensive
than previous years anytime you get a
presidential visit there are inherent
security costs the White House is
providing VIP tickets to Republican
Party donors raising concerns from some
Democratic lawmaker is that the nation's
birthday is being politicized so you can
assure us that the campaign will not use
the 4th of July event in any fundraising
emails or campaign imagery I can assure
you that will act within the legal
limits of what we are allowed to do mr.
Trump got the idea for an elaborate
Washington military parade two years ago
one of the greatest parades I've ever
seen the Federal Aviation Administration
will temporarily shut down on 4th of
July flights in and out of neighboring
Reagan National Airport from 6:15 p.m.
to 7:45 p.m. and again 9:00 p.m. to 9:45
p.m. this to deal with first the
military flyovers and then the long
elaborate fireworks display yeah all
right Thank You major